The Wizarding World is back with its newest
installment.
Will there be beasts?
Will there be secrets?
And will it all be fantastic?
Here’s what you need to know before you
see Fantastic Beasts: The Secrets of Dumbledore.”
Though "Fantastic Beasts: The Secrets of Dumbledore"
originally had a release date in the summer,
it's now set for release on April 15, 2022.
This puts the movie on track to debut just
in time for the Easter holiday.
According to Deadline, this particular opening
weekend has proven to be successful for Warner
Bros. in the past, with hits like "Batman
v Superman: Dawn of Justice" and "Ready Player
One" previously opening to big numbers during
that window.
Both scheduled release dates were a change-up
from the November releases that the first
two "Fantastic Beasts" films employed.
The new date may be an attempt to garner a
higher gross for the third film than its predecessors
achieved; while the first movie grossed over
$814 million worldwide, the sequel brought
in less, at just over $654 million.
A new release season may be an effort to trend
those returns back in the direction of the
blockbuster original "Harry Potter" movies.
Whatever the reasoning, it remains to be seen
if this move will pay off, but if past releases
are any indication, Warner Bros. may be in
for a happy Easter.
According to The Hollywood Reporter, "Fantastic
Beasts: The Secrets of Dumbledore" will pick
up sometime after the second film and continue
to follow Newt Scamander and his friends as
they attempt to stop Grindelwald.
"Who wouldn't like our chances?"
According to an official synopsis for the
movie, "Professor Albus Dumbledore knows the
powerful Dark wizard Gellert Grindelwald is
moving to seize control of the wizarding world.
Unable to stop him alone, he entrusts Magizoologist
Newt Scamander to lead an intrepid team of
wizards, witches and one brave Muggle baker
on a dangerous mission, where they encounter
old and new beasts and clash with Grindelwald's
growing legion of followers.
But with the stakes so high, how long can
Dumbledore remain on the sidelines?"
This synopsis, the film's title, and the trailers
indicate that Law's Dumbledore will play a
much bigger part in the movie than he did
previously, hopefully answering some of the
questions that fans have had for years about
the mysterious wizard.
For fans who noticed a significant change
in Grindelwald's appearance from "The Crimes
of Grindelwald" to "The Secrets of Dumbledore,"
don't worry.
Between flashback sequences, polyjuice potions,
and actor shake-ups, more than a few actors
have played the ruthless dictator throughout
the years.
Yet when "Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find
Them" first unmasked Johnny Depp's version
of the character, Depp seemed like the tried
and true version of this era's Grindelwald.
However, Depp's ongoing legal battle with
ex-wife Amber Heard led to the studio's ultimate
decision to recast the role.
But don't fret.
Mads Mikkelsen is picking up where Depp left
off, and he's sporting an entirely different
look than his predecessor.
Depp's Grindelwald opted for bleach blond
hair and a pallor so gaunt he looked like
he came straight from the morgue.
Mikkelsen's version of the character seems
much less eccentric — right down to the
eyes.
If you look closely, it looks like Grindelwald's
signature heterochromia is still there, but
it's much less pronounced.
Given that Grindelwald is taking his rise
to power to a political level, his stark appearance
change could be attributed to his need to
win over the wizarding population as he begins
his war on muggles.
As he says to Dumbledore,
"With or without you, I'll burn down their
world."
He just apparently needs his suit pressed
to do it.
There may have been a few shakeups in "Fantastic
Beasts" casting, but the majority of the series'
staples from the franchise's first film will
return in "Fantastic Beasts: The Secrets of
Dumbledore."
Of course, there's no "Fantastic Beasts" without
magizoologist Newt Scamander.
Eddie Redmayne plays Newt, the wizarding world's
most notorious (and relatable) Hufflepuff.
Meanwhile, given that the film is titled "The
Secrets of Dumbledore," it's no surprise that
Jude Law is reprising his role as the much
younger Dumbledore.
Also returning is Jacob, the series' main
source of comic relief, played by Dan Fogler.
If the trailers are anything to go by, fans
are getting a healthy dose of Jacob-centric
laughs in the upcoming movie.
Though with a new wand in tow, the wizarding
world's most notorious No-Maj just might be
a No-Maj no more.
As much as fans love the heroes, the villains
are equally exciting for a franchise like
"Fantastic Beasts."
Queenie's descent to Grindelwald's side was
a shock for most fans, but the trailer poses
a few epic villainous moments for her, expertly
carried out by Alison Sudol.
And who could forget Ezra Miller's electric
performance as Credence Barebone as he works
through his trauma while toting an Obscurus?
Grindelwald may be the main show here, but
his lackeys hold their own just fine.
"The Crimes of Grindelwald" introduced fans
to Newt's auror brother Theseus Scamander,
but the new film's trailers imply that Callum
Turner will play a much more significant role
in the quest to take down Grindelwald.
Joining the anti-Grindelwald movement in what
seems like a big way is Jessica Williams'
Ilvermorny charms professor Eulalie Hicks,
following up on her introduction in "The Crimes
of Grindelwald."
And, of course, a trip to Hogwarts wouldn't
be right without a cameo from a young Minerva
McGonagall, who alerts Dumbledore to Grindelwald's
plans.
Fans didn't get many scenes with Newt's "Crimes
of Grindelwald" assistant Bunty, but it looks
like actress Victoria Yeates is returning
for the third film, and the trailer is positioning
her as a soldier in Dumbledore's first army
against Grindelwald.
Poppy Corby-Tuech is also coming back to the
third "Fantastic Beasts" film as Vinda, ready
to fight for Grindelwald with everything she's
got.
Alternatively, William Nadylam's Yusuf Kama
may have had a rocky start in "The Crimes
of Grindelwald," but Leta Lestrange's half-brother
quickly goes from a pseudo-villain to a hero,
spurning Grindelwald's invitation and saving
Nagini.
Though Leta herself met an untimely demise,
Yusuf will be back in "The Secrets of Dumbledore"
to carry on her legacy.
For anyone who hasn't seen "Harry Potter and
the Half-Blood Prince" in a minute, Michael
Gambon's appearance in the second "Fantastic
Beasts: The Secrets of Dumbledore" trailer
may have come as an exciting shock.
However, his cameo is a bit of a bait-and-switch.
While the trailer implies that we may see
an aged-up Dumbledore grace our screens once
more, the clip is just recycled footage from
the sixth "Harry Potter" film.
"That's why he's returning to Hogwarts.
And it's crucial he should return."
The trailer starts with Gambon saying, "Memory
is everything.
Without it, we are blind.
Without it, we leave the fate of our world
to chance."
Of course, this snippet is simply an edited-down
version of Dumbledore's speech to Harry when
he takes the teenage wizard on a trip down
Tom Riddle's memory lane through his Pensieve.
Still, repurposed footage or not, the trailer
raised the question – is Michael Gambon
returning to the wizarding world in "The Secrets
of Dumbledore"?
That's doubtful.
As far as we can tell, it's only in the trailer
for the sake of nostalgia – and grabbing
your attention.
Stranger things have happened in the wizarding
world, but as a different Dumbledore once
said:
"It does not do to dwell on dreams and forget
to live."
The "Fantastic Beasts: The Secrets of Dumbledore"
title sets fans up with serious expectations
in diving into Dumbledore's backstory.
According to Entertainment Weekly, back in
2007, J.K.
Rowling announced that she "always thought
of Dumbledore as gay" and envisioned a relationship
between the Hogwarts headmaster and Grindelwald
– yet the books barely hint at this plotline.
Given that we've gone through two movies that
specifically revolve around young Dumbledore
and Grindelwald, it's been frustrating for
fans to again rely on subtle clues rather
than concrete scenes or conversations detailing
this relationship.
However, we do see the former friends and
possible lovers square off in the trailer,
implying that Dumbledore broke his no-fighting
blood pact with Grindelwald.
Hopefully, fans will also get clarity on the
pair's history and relationship when they
spar.
Like his sexuality, Dumbledore keeps his family
history close to the vest.
However, Hebe Beardsall is returning as Albus
and Aberforth's sister Ariana, and joining
her is Richard Coyle taking on the role of
Albus' brother.
Maybe fans will get answers on what happened
between Aberforth, Ariana, Albus, and Grindelwald
all those years ago.
Presumably fans are more interested in this
history than Harry Potter was.
“I’m not interested in what happened between
you and your brother.”
Though because the trailer teases a big Room
of Requirement moment, Ariana and Aberforth's
cameos might be as superficial as they were
in the “Deathly Hallows.”
It looks like Aberforth is already running
the Hog's Head Inn, while Ariana has long
since passed — making it likely that she'll
resume her role as a portrait guide rather
than a developed character.
There can't be a "Fantastic Beasts" movie
without some fantastic beasts, and it looks
like "The Secrets of Dumbledore" is prepared
to deliver.
Not only do the trailers feature some beloved
creatures like Pickett the Bowtruckle, but
we finally have a name for Newt's trusty Niffler.
Another major beast to make its way into the
trailer is Credence's phoenix — lending
more credence to him being a Dumbledore.
Now, it certainly wouldn't be surprising for
this to be a red herring, but it's equally
possible that there's even more murky family
history surrounding the Dumbledore name than
fans initially thought.
In fact, the title says "The Secrets of Dumbledore,"
not "The Secrets of Albus Dumbledore."
There's a very real possibility that the title
is pointing to the secrets of another Dumbledore
entirely.
Outside of Credence, there are at least two
other Dumbledores in the movie.
Presumably they all have some secrets.
On top of the beasts we have names for, the
trailer depicts a new kind of magical bird,
crab creatures, and a shadowy group of stingers.
All in all, the movie isn't shaping up to
disappoint on creature comforts.
As famed wandmaker Garrick Ollivander likes
to say,
“The wand chooses the wizard, Mr. Potter.”
But for a wand to choose a wizard, the wielder
must be an actual wizard, right?
If you ask any Squib, they'll probably tell
you that a wand on its own doesn't wield all
that much power — it's just a tool, after
all.
Sure, some wands are more potent than others,
but then again, some witches and wizards are
more powerful than others, and wands choose
their match.
So, how is it that No-Maj Jacob is wielding
a wand in "Fantastic Beasts: The Secrets of
Dumbledore"?
In the second "Fantastic Beasts: The Secrets
of Dumbledore" trailer, Dumbledore asks Newt
to give Jacob a wand.
Could there be magic in Jacob after all?
There might be a reason why the wizards let
a muggle tag along on their quests for years
— and an explanation for how he breaks through
a memory wipe.
There are quite a few significant characters
from the "Fantastic Beasts" films whose stories
are currently hanging in plot limbo, waiting
for a revival.
It's certainly possible that some of the seemingly
missing cast members and characters might
show up anyway, but based on available info,
it doesn’t seem likely.
Most notably absent is Claudia Kim, who plays
the human iteration of Voldemort's snake Nagini.
"Crimes of Grindelwald '' faced a significant
amount of backlash for setting the groundwork
for Voldemort to essentially enslave an Asian
woman — and then later encase a portion
of his warped soul inside of her.
Whether Nagini's absence is due to the backlash
against the character, her casting, or because
her arc with Credence is over, it doesn't
look like Nagini will be slithering back for
the newest film.
One significant change from the previous films
that fans may not have noticed has nothing
to do with the cast.
In the first two "Fantastic Beasts" films,
"Harry Potter" author J.K.
Rowling retained sole writing and screenwriting
credits for both movies.
Yet in "Fantastic Beasts: The Secrets of Dumbledore,"
fans may recognize a familiar writing credit
on IMDb: Steve Kloves.
Kloves was responsible for writing seven of
the eight "Harry Potter" films, and now it
looks like Kloves is back on his broomstick
to assist in writing the newest "Fantastic
Beasts" installment.
The real reason for the assist is unknown,
but it could have something to do with the
studio trying to minimize Rowling’s involvement
with the film in light of her recent transphobic
statements.
Or, it’s possible, she just didn’t want
to write the movie solo.
Regardless, the movie will see yet another
returning Harry Potter veteran behind the
camera besides Kloves: director David Yates.
Yates is a "Potter" staple, having directed
"The Order of the Phoenix" through "Deathly
Hallows: Part 2" and continuing his reign
through the first two "Fantastic Beasts" films.
The director returns for "Fantastic Beasts:
The Secrets of Dumbledore" to add a level
of continuity that's rare for a franchise
so massive.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.